la glotte du jour appelle la question
orale de madame catherine procaccia me
suis mise de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'attire par cette question l'attention
sur les conséquences des délais
particulièrement long pour la
présentation à l'examen du permis de
conduire dans le val de marne en france
le délai moyen entre la fin de la
formation pratique et l'examen varie de
quelques semaines à deux mois dans mon
département il atteignait 6 mois lorsque
j'ai posé cette question au mois de
juillet c'est presque maintenant huit
mois
qu'il faut attendre à des personnes qui
ont raté pour la pro la première fois
leur examen pour pouvoir être réinscrit
une telle situation est embarrassante
pour les élèves qui doit faire face à
des coûts qui ne sont pas prévus dans
les forfaits qu'ils ont souscrits avant
même qu'ils passent l'épreuve théorique
du code entre la dernière heure de
formation et le passage à l'examen de
nombreux élèves doivent donc reprendre
des leçons supplémentaires d'une ou deux
heures par mois pour conserver leurs
acquis ce surcoût imprévue est source de
relations conflictuelles entre les auto
écoles et leurs élèves puisque les
élèves ne comprennent pas qu'elle doive
attendre aussi longtemps et que ce n'est
pas à cause de l'auto école et si
l'élève a échoué une première fois ses
coûts deviennent absolument exorbitant
compte tenu des délais l'obtention du
permis de conduire est essentiel vous le
savez pour trouver un travail il est
indispensable à la mobilité y compris en
ile de france où les transports en
commun ne sont pas présents partout et
roulent est difficile d'aller d'un
endroit à l'autre ce rallongement des
délais est dénoncée par les
professionnels depuis 2010 dans le val
de marne le préfet avait alors décidé à
titre exceptionnel de faire appel à des
inspecteurs d'autres départements pour
débloquer la situation à titre de
comparaison il y a moins d'inspecteurs
dans le val de marne qu'en bretagne eu
égard à la population une seule personne
s'occupe de lui enregistrement des
dossiers qui sont déposés à créteil il
faut au moins 4 mois pour qu'une auto
écoles obtiennent le renouvellement de
son agrément quinquennal monsieur le
ministre pouvez vous me dire quelles
mesures comprendre dans l'immédiat le
ministre de l'intérieur pour désengorger
cette situation critique en val de marne
et quelles mesures durables veut-il
mettre en oeuvre pour que les élèves qui
attendent n'attendent plus aussi
longtemps pour les inspecteurs qui ne
sont pas assez nombreux et pour les auto
écoles dont certaines sont à la veille
d'un dépôt de bilan à cause de ces
dysfonctionnements
merci merci mes chers collègues parole
de monsieur victorin lurel ministre d
outre mer
madame la sénatrice catherine de cassia
vous avez interrogé le ministre de
l'intérieur sur l'importance des délais
pour la présentation à l'examen du
permis de conduire notamment dans votre
département du val de marne
manuel valls regrette de ne pouvoir être
présent parmi nous ce matin il m'a
cependant transmis les éléments de
réponse suivant
l'accès au permis de conduire est un
sujet important car comme vous l'avez
rappelé le permis n'est pas une simple
autorisation administrative
il est pour beaucoup de jeunes synonyme
d'accès à l'autonomie à l'emploi bref à
l'âge adulte
comme vous le savez le nombre de places
auxquelles chaque école de conduite peut
prétendre représenter les candidats à
l'épreuve pratique est fixé selon une
méthode nationale qui tient compte
notamment de la réussite de chaque école
durant les 12 derniers mois
cette méthode d'attribution est complété
par plusieurs dispositifs qui permettent
d'augmenter l'offre d'examen au niveau
départemental lorsque celle ci est
saturé
renfort d'inspecteurs de départements
proches mis en place un examen
supplémentaire le samedi par exemple ces
dispositifs permettent d'accorder des
renforts ponctuels au département dont
le délai d'attenté entre deux
présentations est supérieure à la
moyenne nationale en particulier à
certaines périodes de l'année
correspondant à un afflux des deux
mondes la mise en oeuvre de ces mesures
a permis d'obtenir pour l'année 2012 un
délai moyen d'attenté d'environ 86 jours
au niveau national
86 jours dans le département du val de
marne ce délai supérieur avec 120 jours
même s'il n'atteint pas la durée de six
mois que vous avez mentionné ce délai
reste trop long c'est pourquoi le val de
marne a bénéficié au cours des neuf
premiers mois de l'année 2013 d'environ
son examen supplémentaire par mois
ce qui correspond à un renfort
équivalent à un inspecteur du permis de
conduire et de la sécurité routière à
temps plein de plus la longueur des
délais dans ce département s'explique
aussi par un taux de réussite à l'examen
inférieur au taux national sur l'année
51,58 % dans le val de marne quand 59,13
pourtant sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour autant le ministre de l'intérieur
est conscient de la nécessité d'ouvrir
une réflexion globale sur la question
des places d'examen
c'est pourquoi il a demandé à la
présidente de la commission jeunes et
éducation routière du conseil national
de la sécurité routière de mener une
concertation élargie sur ce sujet est de
proposer un plan d'action
merci madame profession
merci monsieur le ministre je suis bien
conscient que vous êtes le porte-parole
du texte du gouvernement est mais j'ai
vu qu'aussi en outre-mer il y avait
aussi des problèmes de présentation de
permis de conduire il n'y a pas qu'en
ile de france ce que je veux simplement
signaler c'est que cette durée moyenne
et ce taux de réussite on ne peut pas si
on se base sur le taux moyen en nylon
entre l'île de france le val de marne et
le reste de la france dire que 52% c'est
un taux d'échec plus faible mais c'est
normal vous avez vous circuler en ile de
france vous voyez que sur une heure de
conduite on peut passer 45 minutes
bloqués dans des encombrements donc
effectivement en ile-de-france et dans
notre département il faut plus de de
conduite puisque l'on ne conduit pas
dans les mêmes situations et que lorsque
l'on est en province et bien pour une
heure de conduite vous conduisez une
heure et non pas 30 ou 40 minutes comme
c'est le cas chez nous dans cette région
ça peut expliquer le taux ce qui
explique aussi le taux beaucoup plus
faible c'est qu'il ya de nombreux
nombreuses personnes qui passent le
permis il y a eu
6445 personnes qui ont passé l'examen au
premier trimestre dans le val de marne à
peu près 48 % simplement l'ont eu et
entre temps il y en a eu il ya eu 2848
demande j'ai fait le calcul monsieur le
ministre ça veut dire que sur l'année on
va avoir 25 mille personnes qui sont qui
ont demandé le père qui a demandé le
permis de conduire et on en a douze
mille en attente puisque on ne peut pas
réserver le taux donc il ya une
réflexion qui est menée peut-être mais
il faut tenir compte du stock et non pas
du flux permanent en ile de france la
situation est plus tendue qu'ailleurs je
trouve qu'il faudrait faire quelque
chose sans compter que 1/3 des examens
ont été annulés suite à la grève des
inspecteurs de mois de décembre et bien
si un tiers ont été annulés ça va encore
augmenter le nombre de personnes et
encore retarder le passage de tous et de
tous ces jeunes j'espérais monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur dirais-je mais momentanément
des moyens supplémentaires à disposition
de la préfecture en mettant une personne
de plus pour examiner les dossiers en
mettant une personne qui puisse regarder
le réexamen des autorisations des
auto-écoles c'est quand même absolument
incroyable qu'on des auto écoles ça fait
quatre mois que vous avez demandé votre
dépôt de dossier mais je peux pas le
réexaminer votre agrément donc je vous
le donne d'office tendrait à éliminer
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens ce sont
quand même des situations qui sont
complètement aberrante on m'annonce une
concertation ça veut dire que vous
annoncez monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur et non pas vous monsieur
lurel mais mini d'intérieurs annonce
clairement et simplement à tous les gens
du val de marne aux inspecteurs
aux auto écoles et aux jeunes et moins
jeunes qui passent leur permis de
conduire quand rien n'est prévu pour
améliorer la situation rapidement